this past weekend
there was a ufc fight i don't know if
there was ufc was it 261 261 i believe
it was right 261 times
262. 262 and i'm sitting at the house
and friends are calling me telling me
you know this assyrian guy's is fighting
and i said the witcher syrian guy says
domain is
is uh in the assyrian community they
respect our usual but daryush is a
persian name so hey this guy's
you know he's been talking a lot about
the you know you got to take a look at
him so i've never seen him fight i've
only seen the highlights so then i see
him fight and he goes up against
can you pull up uh uh what he said at
the end of the fight i think he goes up
against
who's the guy he's going up against it's
a big fighter 37 year old who's
not at the best he was on a two uh fight
uh yeah it was the co-main event so it
was
what's his name went up against uh
can somebody help me out here if you're
watching this somebody has to know who
it is who was he going up against he was
going up against
bernie sanders not bernie sanders book
but tony ferguson
and tony's a legendary fighter the guy's
a bees if you've seen this guy fight
before the guy's a
knockout artist just a rock star they
fight
assyrian daruch wins okay daniel wins
at the end of the fight rogan's
interviewing the guy in the middle of
the interview what do you typically say
you know i want to call out such and
such i want to go after this guy
i want to go after that guy he says this
at the end of his fight after he wins
i want to dedicate this fight to all the
people
who've been hurt by marxist ideologies
there are millions of you and i know it
and it's just a fight i know it's not
much but i want you to know that i love
you and i understand the pain
i don't completely understand but i love
you and i i understand your pain
can you imagine you use your platform to
talk about that yeah coming from an
assyrian who just want to fight that's
i think it's a six seven match win
streak or six match win streak yeah it's
amazing he has faculties together at the
end of that fight to do that they they
you they know everybody's watching them
it's a forum for them to say what they
want you know joe rogan's going um
book him for my next podcast sounds
really interesting you know what else he
said what's that he called out elon musk
so he literally did this kind of thing
he could pull that up too so after he
did the message about marxism destroying
the world and feeling the pain of
everybody that's under the influence of
that
he he called out elon musk because the
delivery of his wife's car
is late late and he's got a daughter on
the way and he wants her protected and
elon actually responded to that
so you can see these guys probably in
the middle of the match they're thinking
all right
i got to get this win so i could have
this huge political message
thank the right people most of them are
setting up their next fight so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you